Hey guys, I am back in the lab again today,
and I brought back my silicone chicken mold
because there's an experiment I want to try with a chocolate chicken
but this one is going to have a twist.
I went down to the supercenter and picked up some of these coloured melting chocolates.
Now, these are basically just white chocolate with food colouring added
but they're all pre-coloured for you.
So basically all we have to do is throw these in the microwave, melt them down
and pour them into our mold.
The only question I have, is with these being different colours,
do you think the colours will meld together, and make this thing look terrible,
or will the colours retain their individuality, and give us a cool rainbow effect?
Let's find out!
I did a quick google image search to find a picture of a rainbow, and you can see,
red is at the top and purple is at the bottom.
and so if we want our chocolate chicken to come out the same,
we need to start by pouring in the red first, and the purple last.
so that when we turn the chicken over, the rainbow will be in the proper direction, at least that's the theory.
Now if you read the directions it says you should put this chocolate in the microwave half power for 30 seconds at a time
massage the bag in between sessions to full constitute the choclate
however im not that patient I find if you just put it in full power for 60 seconds,30 seconds,and 10 seconds it has the same effect
so remember 60,30,10 you can follow the directions if you want at least that is  what works well for me in my microwave
our first 60 seconds is up and some of this chocolate is melted and some of it is not.
so we are going to message the bag to spread the temperature evenly throughout all the chocolate inside
Alright so we are going to throw that back in for another 30 seconds and wait patiently
*evil laughter*
starting to feel pretty good
There is just a few solid clumps left in there to get out
i think 10 more seconds will do the trick
so this is the fun part all we have to do now is take a pair of scissors  snip off our corner and pour it into our mold
just going to smear that around so kinda gets into all kinds of cracks and crevices here.Just for fun
So red is done orange is next
Oo that looks really cool
Looks like cheese.Looks like melted cheese wizz
Cool so we got red and orange next step yellow
Artificial vanilla flavor ummm
Ok yellow is up next
Last bag of chocolate guys all we have to do is snip he tip and pour it in
I don't we could have planned that much better I think its going to come out practically perfect in every way
Finish up with a nice purple base
huuuuu look at that
That's about as good as it gets
So update guys our chocolate chicken mold is full of six different colors of chocolate I hope as long they didn't jiggle and melt together in the process
I'm really curious to know how this is going to turn up but we don't know until we put it in the fridge and give 6-8 hours to set so lets do that next
Our chocolate is in the fridge and its gonna take a few hours for it to fully set up so while we are waiting let me tell you about the company that sponsored this project
A food delivery service called Blue Apron
Blue Apron is a service that allows you to create delicious chef designed recipes at home
They deliver all the farm fresh ingredients right your door step in exactly the right proportions so no trips to the grocery store and no waste from unused ingredients
They offer two types of plans there is the two person plan and the the family plan
Blue Apron recipes are delivered in refrigerated box ingredient stays fresh even if your are not at home we they arrive
The company offers a large selection of recipes and is always adding new dishes to their menu every week and they ship about any where in the USA
There is no long term commitments you can skip or cancel the service any time you want the shipping is always free
That looks amazing I can't wait to eat it
I put a like down in the description so you can go check them out and the first 100 people to get there will get three free meals included in their first purchase
All the meals can be made in about forty minutes or less and all the ingredients are fresh and source from local supplier
Tastes like chicken so go check them out Blue Apron they deliver right your door the links down in the description
The time has come guys our rainbow chocolate chicken has been sitting in the fridge for 5 hours now so I think its firm enough that we can pull it out of the mold
Did the colors stay separate or did they combine into some globby  mess now is the time that we find out
The purple came out pretty nice
Look at these pieces here.This is were I let some of the chocolate smeared over and if we press that we it actually brake off but this is that chocolate and eat them
Don't tell anyone
There we go this is the fun part taking the silicon off
Now its very important with this chicken we go slowly enough that we don't brake one of the legs like it did last time
Oh man this already starting to look cool it got really awesome marble effect look down here you see yellow,purple,green that blending with others beautifully
Start to get excited
Starting to get a glimpse of the chicken in here look at that
hahahaha oh my goodness that is amazing it looks like it might actually work
We got both the legs in tagged this time that encouraging
AAAAAA I feel that releasing
There we go hahaha check that out guys
One half of our chicken and that is looking rainbow.That is actually really cool that came out of a lot better than I expected
This looks like a candy chicken you could eat
hahahaha look at that guys the world's first rainbow chocolate chicken
That looks really cool I mean if you look at its bottom side there you see he is filled with all kinds of rainbow colors
So apparently all the different chocolate layers did stay separate.They didn't combine after all and it actually gives a really cool effect.This thing looks epic
Now I made a chocolate chicken just out of milk chocolate it kinda look gross because it looked a little bit too real
This looks like a fun funky chicken like I just want to dig my teeth into this thing that is awesome
Well guys I think we are going to call this a success.We have the world's first rainbow chocolate chicken how cool it that
and other than just wanting to sink my teeth into this thing there is only one other urge that I had that is glide a hot knife through it
Now I been in Texas for the last couple of weeks I'm a little bit late to the hot knife challenge but I went ahead and picked up a kitchen knife anyway as well as couple
of propane torches.So if you guys want to see it leave a comment below and I will heat that knife and glide it through this chicken so we can see how it looks inside
In the mean time I going to stick this thing back in the fridge so it can stay nice and firm until tomorrow and
I will be looking for you in the next video talk to you then
Hey guys thanks for watching and remember I'm giving away prizes now on every new video.All you have to do to
qualify is subscribe to my channel ,ring the bell and  select to be notified when my next video get released
The secret link to my give away will be pinned in the comments for the first 12 hours
If you like what I'm doing sure you support right now by giving this video a big thumbs up and share with a friend.I love you back and see you next time